talk to somebody who actually talked i
mean you talked to james but let's talk
to somebody who talks to gm
on a daily basis no no no you do you do
i was gonna say you actually does but
you do
but you do i know vinnie goodwill from
yahoo talks to gm's
okay vinny we'll get to the firing of
doc in a second which i think you more
or less called
uh last time you were on the show but on
a mutual departure whatever you want to
characterize it but just settle that for
us settle that for us real quick vinnie
go back to the off season when in order
to get kawhi to sign with the clippers
they mortgaged their future and gave it
to oklahoma city for paul george
no no no no no wait wait don't say it
that way say what the
you say what the good thing is go ahead
stay with the compensation
i think it was five first i think it's
five first round picks and two players
am i right or am i right vinny is that
what it was five first round picks and
two players
swaps and now i'm running i'm running
count i'm losing count
of how many times how many players picks
and pick swaps and everything else
yeah it's kind of tricky but i will
grant you guys this
today's media day for the nba finals
correct
pat riley is the godfather of the miami
heat
he came there in 1995 that he did not
have any identity
they barely made the playoffs they're a
franchise in infancy
his first seven years he won three
playoff series
except they stuck with him and then
years later
he became the godfather so the clippers
could have stuck with them too
and came up with the same result
um maybe maybe potentially
but wait but just do me a favor just
answer that one question though
what was it in hindsight in retrospect
do you as an expert or people around the
league believe that the clippers
overpaid
for this potentially two-year experiment
with kawhi leonard and paul george
you you overpay because these players
don't come along
too often and players don't choose the
la clippers like let's get it serious
y'all
chris paul didn't choose the la clippers
in a traditional way he was sent there
blake griffin was drafted by them the
only reason kawaii leonardo was going to
the clippers was because
there was too much going on with the
lakers so you do what you have to do
as a franchise of non-consequence as the
clippers are to get the players
look i'm not saying that kawhi leonard
and paul george are halle berry
but if you got to pay 500 to go on one
date with halle berry you going to pay
it
or is that overpaying 500.
who knows that's 500.
[Laughter]
you at the beginning of the night my
your pockets better be deeper than that
but let me ask you something look we
were talking about it and and mike smith
and i we we
both agree that you know we we cut docks
and breaks
just because it's dock i mean come on
stop but
3-1 he's up 3-1 over the denver nuggets
and as you look back what what
percentage
of blame would you put on doc for that
series loss to the nuggets
i think when you talk about the series
loss in the vacuum you can only put so
much on them because that team was so
disjointed right
lou williams looked like he did not want
to be there and didn't play well
montrezl his personal stuff going on
paul george
well documented his own issues going on
and kawhi leonard we don't know how well
he responds from playing
every other day for two months in a row
what i will grant you guys what i will
grant doc level of graces on
is that this team did not have an encore
leader
it did not have a chris paul did not
have a genre when you look at teams in
the finals now
the lakers in the heat they have players
on the floor vocal leaders
who can mirror exactly what the coach in
the front office
the mantra is there was no player like
that for the la clippers kawhi leonard
is a leader by example
and you can't make kawhi leonard be
anything that he is not
you know the roster maybe that's not
solely on doc rivers
but if you're talking about how the team
was coached in that playoff series
if you're good enough to be up 3-1
you're good enough to win the series
and they didn't close it out and that
has to be partly
on this span of head head coach
did you this this was the news of of the
night
last night when it happened you know
about uh 5 15 or so eastern
um and i text you immediately i'm not
gonna repeat what i text you like
you're coming on tomorrow right um i
mean in the time between they lost
their the time between when they lost to
the nuggets and yesterday
did you have an inkling just as a
reporter as an insider that this
might be coming or were you even shocked
when it happened
i think i was a little shocked at the
timing of it i thought this would be
something if it was going to happen it
was going to happen quick
but it being on the eve of nba finals
media day
right where the lakers are taking center
stage
yet again i don't think it's a
coincidence that the clippers decide to
do this news dump the day before
and the fact that it was so many days of
deliberation it was almost like a jury
going into quarters right where we're
going to figure out if doc is guilty or
not guilty you're going to talk to the
players
you're going to talk to the front office
you're going to talk to ownership and
some of ownership's people
and then you're going to come up with a
conclusion i i think doc was a little
surprised
because of the timing of it i think if
you're going to do it you could have
done it immediately in the aftermath
or maybe you want ty lue and you don't
want ty
to go too far down the line with the
philadelphia 76ers
all right vinnie next best move for doc
and next and next
best move for the clippers next
best move for doc i'm not a fan of him
going to the philadelphia 76ers i know
they like him
i know they want him i'm sure he could
be useful there
but what about that situation that said
stability
and anything other than dysfunction
right
so if i'm doc rivers i got two years
left
i'll go to the tv booth i'll go to the
tv studio
i'll put some lotion on the vocal cords
and i will chill out for a couple years
and wait until the next best job
opportunity opens up you don't have to
take one right now
and it's not like doc rivers it's like
most other black coaches where if you do
not take the next best opportunity you
don't get one
dockets kind of bypass that and he'll
get the velvet rope treatment i believe
for his next opportunity because
honestly you're talking about the
philadelphia 76ers
but ben simmons can't shoot won't you
and joel embiid has
either a bad back or bad knees and
that's a ticking time bomb
and that organization does not seem like
something that i would necessarily feel
comfortable walking into
and how about the clippers who's there
who's their next person
honestly guys what that's not the answer
tyloo
and not just from the standpoint that
he's the next best guy in line and
everything else but
schematically from the x-snow standpoint
tyloo's a much better coach than people
have given them credit for people
look at him as like lebron's guy and
everything else but from the x's and
those standpoint
that cleveland cavaliers team was well
prepared and well executed especially
when you consider guys like kevin love
and kyrie irving who aren't necessarily
want to play defense and you had lebron
who he had to convince
to play defense during different sport
first so
i will say some of the things that the
clippers like schematically i think ty
luke can sort of fill in those blanks
and add to the fact that he's not a guy
that's afraid to challenge
paul george and kawhi leonard when
they're not playing up the snuff so i
would say he would be their best choice
out of all these guys i'm not
necessarily a fan of the jeff van
gundy's or some of these other guys out
here
i would at least be willing to give a
chance to a guy who knows that
organization
and has some championship skins on the
wall
yeah i agree with doc man that would be
my prescription for doc is to take a
sabbatical which
we all need sabbaticals you know what i
mean um
and i think he just needs to recharge uh
spend some time with his family
frankly we talked about earlier and you
notice vinnie like how how um
integral he was and and how influential
and how important he was
in this conversation uh that emanated
from the bubble
around uh racial and social justice how
much of a leader he's been
i love to see what kind of work he could
do in that arena um
if he so chose not not obligating him to
but if he so chose
i love to see you know what he can do in
this moment that we're in right now
as well as you know how great he'd be
you know back on television or whatever
and in a couple of years
he'll probably look that much better to
people you know right now
certainly he would be a great hire for
any of those organizations looking for
a coach but it feels like
you know once he's away from it for a
minute he'll be recharged
and it'll be that much more of an
appetite or desire
for somebody like doc rivers a year or
so removed from this collapse don't you
think vinny
i mean think about it like this doc
river stepped into the la clip in 2013
and six months after he got there donald
sterling and visteviano was
placed into his lap and he had to take
the head of that
organization the worst organization in
sports
he had to assuage all the team employees
he had to steer the players through a
potential boycott
and actually coach the team and then he
took over as team president
and maybe he was a little overqualified
underqualified for that position maybe
that was too much for him
but he's had a lot on his plate since
he's gotten there and maybe he's due for
a little bit of rest especially when you
consider
and of all the coaches in black all the
black culture in sports
he's the most respected he's the voice
that speaks with clarity
with passion with emotion and like and
honestly guys
respected by white people that's a
burden yeah
hmm uh and you mentioned black coaches
in sports the nba
has four of them four
so that's one more by the way vinnie
that's one more than major league
baseball
so can we start calling the black can we
call black league
thank you thank you so what's going
what's going on though what what what is
your just what is your analysis
uh of this because the numbers have just
gone down
sharply in the last seven or eight years
i think it's a number of things guys and
the analytics movement
is not necessarily against the black
coaches but there are not black coaches
who are integrated
into that world right so when you talk
about speaking of owner's language and
you talk about so many new owners who
come from the financial sector
or the private sector and that's the way
that they made their money they don't
identify with black culture with these
black experiences
in my book it looks like moving the goal
post
you see all these guys with so many
experiences how many black coaches do
you see
on the sidelines but are not in the
first chair were there the quote unquote
players coach
or they're the guy who can kind of talk
to the guys when when things go wrong
that's their value it's not necessarily
being a face
of the franchise and when you look at it
like this i
i think about like this guys you can
make the case
for three quarters of the coaches in the
nba being fired just like you can make
the
case for the same thing in the nfl it's
the benefit of the doubt that black
coaches don't get relative to their
counterparts i just brought up to you
pat riley in 1995 when he came in with
the
miami heat and the fact that he had
fallen short of expectations he hit the
chicago bulls to deal with right
doc whippers had the golden state
warriors that came out of nowhere and
became a dynasty and yet that wasn't
held up
as a reason to keep him aboard but
everything else was in line for doc
rivers and the clippers to take over
we talk about benefit of the doubt that
is not necessarily being held up for
black coaches in any sport you can find
any reason to fire a black coach if you
want to and you can find any reason to
hire a white coach
and often times that's what we see it's
not necessarily outright racism
but you kind of have a hard time
convincing me that it doesn't have
something to do with race
it's got it's got a lot to do with it
because i mean first of all let's focus
on the fact that we're strictly just
talking about coaches
we're not even talking about general
managers and ownership is
is might as well be star trek final
frontier you know when it comes to black
ownerships
because somebody told me somebody told
me this uh i was talking to a former nfl
gm
and i like the way he put it he said uh
he said when it comes to black gm's we
are
uh elevated we're not hired as in a lot
of times
it's guys from within the organization
as opposed to
an organization actively seeking out
outside candidates and finding uh a
qualified uh
doing the work to find a quality it's
not that hard to find a qualified black
candidate but in terms of the coaches
though
um it is a problem but there's a
solution staring right in the face in
terms of the fact that there are now
with doc
moving on from la now there are six
vacancies in the nba
so to really be interesting and i know
you know they always hide behind it's an
organization or an individual
organizational decision but it feels
like there needs to be some kind of
meeting some kind of conference call
and say look houston india houston in
particular but
also indiana philadelphia oklahoma city
new orleans
it's like hey guys let's not drop the
ball
another six times when it comes to this
because i had this conversation
with a friend of mine talking about
steve nash and remember that com
vinnie you remember that obviously we
weren't on the air then but that
conversation was happening whether it
was white privilege and it wasn't right
privilege
and everybody was on opposite extremes
like one side or the other
it's white privilege no it's not you
know why you playing the so-called race
card
and i said both things can be true at
the same time
steve nash can be qualified it could be
a decision driven by kevin durant and
kyrie irving he could have had a
relationship with duran going back to go
to state he could be a basketball savant
and the white privilege still be
involved because like you said a second
ago vinnie the goal post keep getting
moved
just because you can find other black
coaches
who were hired with no coaching
experience
doesn't mean that every time you look
the qualifications
differ and there's always you know uh
opportunities for white coaches that
they just aren't for black assistant
coaches
continuing to buy their time and pay
their dues on the bench
but yet when it's time to actually get
elevated there's always a reason to hire
somebody else you know so
it's true it's two things they got an
opportunity to fix it
it's two things you talk about the black
assistant coaches right
if you're in the black assistant coach
and you've been on the sidelines for too
long
then there's a problem about hey why
hasn't he gotten a head coaching job as
opposed to him being
well deserved if you're too young then
you haven't paid your dues enough
there's never a good enough sweet spot
right
for someone to say that you're not
you're too young you're not old enough
or or vice versa that makes white people
feel comfortable with a black coach
getting a head coaching job
and the second point i think it speaks
to the the macro
of all executive hirings across all
sports
to me it's benefit of the dollar
whenever there's a black coach to me
that's in london black executive that's
in line
ownership always talks about let's cast
a wide net
why does that sound like code for white
that sounds like let's go find the best
white person we can find
let's go get to one of these search
firms who's going to tell us a bunch of
things that we already know
and let's go hire the most qualified
white guy who makes us feel comfortable
and let's pay them a million dollars to
say that we
cast a wide net that's what i that's the
bs that i'm talking about
yeah uh yo before we let you go homie
uh we got to get you on record with a
finals pick what you got
and how many games well first i have a
minor grievance before i give you my
my finals pick oh let's get the great
florida i want to hear the grievance
yours do y'all hate
that microsoft word looking nba finals
logo that we got right now
i know i wasn't prepared to have the
graphics up and everything why does
everything look so bland with the nba
remember the final script
the cursive they had to look so good and
elegant all this
and now somebody in the league office
who done crushed the number and said
let's make everything look like
microsoft word so we can get
youtube at the bottom of it that that's
my minor grump i know that's like old
man yelling that crowd and all that and
i'm this old folk
but i like the nba finals looking like
the nba planners as opposed to looking
like you know
high school in the backyard or
[Music]
it's bubble basketball what do you
expect bubble basketball
i expect something better holly that's
what i expect
[Laughter]
but to my to my finals pick i'm not
gonna get caught picking against the
miami heat again
they don't have the two best players wow
they don't have
the x factor i think they got the better
coach
and they got the team that doesn't know
that can't afford to lose
i don't think pat riley and eric
sposcher even though they don't play
can afford to lose this series to lebron
james
you got bam mata mario who matches up
perfectly with anthony davis
you get jimmy butler who can match up
perfectly along with andre iguodala
with lebron james all that being said
i'm picking the lakers in seven
[Laughter]
and i was feeling good i'm like the
expert on my side i'm like vinnie
goodwill
feeling my pick i'm like i'm feeling all
credible and whatnot
call me a wuss i'm gonna call you a bus
i'm gonna do that
i don't have this to pick the heat you
thought about it
you thought about it you don't really
have the you don't really have the
cookie talking you don't really have the
courage to pick the lakers if you're
picking them in seven
i mean somebody in seven you know that's
like i don't know
somebody you know it's seven come on
vinnie go pick him in six
pick him at six or really disrespect him
pick him in five pick a gentleman's
fault
go ahead ain't no disrespect here if it
goes to seven
i feel good that i'm saying that anybody
can win
that series and that's basically
whatever you gotta go with lebron if it
goes to seven
you gotta go to the broader goal seven
you gotta you gotta pick a king in game
seven
and scott foster
always a pleasure brother we appreciate
you vinny good to see you
[Laughter]